what's up y'all it's your boy boss check
me out
on the bootleg kev show
yo boulet kev show special guest in here
my guy
boss is here man what's going on bro
appreciate you yes sir man it's been a
you've had a hell of a a year so far for
real we kind of just getting it started
but you know
like all years there's a lot of plotting
involved beforehand a hundred percent
man
um talk about like you know
first of all milky way it feel like it's
been a few years when would milky way
come out 2018
2018 yeah so it's been like i mean
obviously you've been active since then
you know uh the dreamful album yeah yeah
so it's not like you ain't been you know
but but
i'm sure this body of work that you're
cooking up has got to be
worth the wait you know you're taking it
i'm always trying to
um like evolve and grow and bring
something new with every project so
i think you know obviously everyone had
a year but we had to take a step back
but
i kind of put that to use and just tried
to
keep reinventing my style and keep
adding you know keep adding new levels
to it
yeah it's crazy because um on cole's
album like when i first pressed play i
don't think you could see the features
on there when i don't know however i was
listening i couldn't see any of the
features
right so i was just pressing play and
then i went on twitter and i was like yo
that was boss
like yeah dipping into your melody back
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah you know just trying to grow
out the comfort zone i was down there
with cole
um that's one thing you know we were
kind of preaching
and throughout that whole process we
actually did the jackie like those same
like
three four days that i was down there
working on so that
that record happened during the
off-season sessions yeah yeah it was
like
cole has like a very set time he'd be in
the studio right he got a lot of other
things going on so
we had like 30 minutes left i think we
had just finished doing like some
background vocals on
on one of the records might have been
like let go of my hand and um
he was like yo let's pull up a beat and
just like do something in like 30.
so he pulled up a t-minus folder first b
he played was the jackie
we just looked at each other like yeah
like don't say less like pull that one
up
yeah got on the mic and um you know just
challenging ourselves not to
to feel some things you know what i mean
as opposed to like be so clinical with
the writing and
just trying to push yourself out of that
comfort zone like i'm usually the type
to sit there and like
get all my words right and then be like
all right you know i'm ready to do my
verse and i was like you know what not
just get on there
and do what you feel you know what i
mean do like what comes to you like
naturally
and then you know you can refine it from
there and go back and and work on how
clever you want to make it
right or whatnot but there's certain
things you can't replace
you know and that's something like i'll
even watch like some of the some of the
younger kids now
that's all they do you know that's all
they do they'll just go fill out the
beat in the booth
yeah and then worry about filling in the
lyrics and [ __ ] later yeah right
right and there's there's you know i
feel like there's something to learn
from everyone's process for sure and now
something i was able to
kind of apply to myself like you know
just just let loose a little bit like
don't even think about like what's the
melody that comes to you what
you know what i mean what's the feeling
that comes to you and you know we did
the jackie in like 30 minutes
so that's kind of new for your process
usually you would just like
yeah i'm gonna write some ill [ __ ] right
i'm gonna go as hard as i can
right even if i have the melody like
i'll sit there and i'll write
the song out you know and then i'll go
like laid down and this was just more
like
all right what are these first four bars
boom what are the next four bars okay
now how do we
you know take it somewhere different you
know for the listener how do we keep it
dynamic
right um it was a it was a fun
process for sure and cole was there the
whole time like just like
you know trying to keep pushing me out
of my comfort zone that's how we did a
lot of
his records and then it just kind of
spilled over into the gym i was gonna
say like
like for his records like was did he
have like a vision for where you were
like fitting in on these joints yeah so
i did this song
called risk with fkj french kiwi juice
shout out my guy did that like probably
a year and a half ago
and on that i was doing a lot of those
melodies and stacking my vocals and
you know doing a bunch of that stuff and
when we came in to work on kohl's album
he was like i want that boss you know
he said i want to i want you to work on
that more and like bring that energy to
these songs
um so me me and kay quick who records me
he's a a producer engineer all that but
he's also like
an incredible vocalist you know so he's
really good at
kind of pointing out certain things or
you know try it in this tone try it in
that song we just sat there every night
and we figured it out like whatever song
cole gave us
we just sit in the room and be like okay
like let's bring the wave to it
yeah it's crazy because the one thing
that i took like from like the process
for offseason that i really appreciated
about somebody who's
as big as cole is on the mount rushmore
right now you know like
was it seem like he really was extremely
dedicated to making sure he was better
at wrapping this go-round
like yeah you know like i watched the
documentary i was like yo this fool's
like really like
almost like in the gym like in both ways
because he was
training in the gym as well but like on
on on some
bar [ __ ] as well like i feel like this
is the sharpest um
he's ever been on like lyrically and
it's crazy to say that
um so so many years in but did that
inspire you and like
your album or like the way you're kind
of approaching i mean yeah it definitely
especially
when i had spent most of the year just
working at the crib by myself
and i'm a very collaborative artist so
it's good to get in again with bro and
then
also just to see like you know here's a
there's a dude who has the world
and he's like so focused every day on
getting better
you know what i mean like what's your
excuse yeah um
that'll definitely like just light a
fire under you or you know
just make you feel like i can and i
should be doing more
100 man um do we have
there's there's speculation that you're
supposed to announce your album with
elliott one this is going to come out
after that
oh no are you are you announcing an
album okay
no no i'm saying we
but we're getting an album before the
end of the year of course yeah yeah
before the end of the year yeah for sure
i just been in a zone though honestly
where i try to be intentional with
everything i do
and when i look at it and i'm like you
know i'm very proud
of the albums i've made and and when i
look at the challenges that i
set for myself it was a song like the
jackie
um you know i got another single in the
works
that i'm really excited about um and i'm
i'm just kind of challenging myself to
make
bigger records even like what we said
earlier about the energy is different
around this one you feel me
it's like trying to challenge myself
like what is
the next frontier in my own career what
is the next
you know what are the next levels i want
to hear what are the next things i want
to challenge myself as an artist to
create
you know what i mean so it's like i feel
like
i'm always going to be in love with
making a cohesive
body of work you know that's going to
give you like my mentality
but a lot of what i've been challenging
myself to do is like
make make these big records yeah how do
you elevate how do you know yeah
exactly so that's that's been like a
major focus of mine i've tried
to really stay intentional with that
yeah no i think like
i would you know i think you're s as you
have
incredible fan base but i still think
in in in terms of like the grand scheme
of
who just talks about you slept on still
yeah absolutely i agree you know what i
mean
like there's not a lot of people who
have an album better than two high riot
you know what i'm saying right thank you
but like i think that um
i mean you're right like you got it like
yo you got to get some people to come to
the party yeah
you can't lie to yourself you got to
look at where you are where you want to
be
and the things you got to achieve to get
there you know and then and the beauty
of it is like
the art of it is doing it you know
within your sound
within like all the songs i'm making
even the jackie like
my fan base don't hear that and be like
what the hell yeah like what is he doing
man he sold out not for sure if you
heard milky way it's kind of like a
a direct like 100 percent enough of that
kind of sound and that vibe and that
energy
so it's like that's the fun part of it
is like okay i like i know my sound i
figured out my sound
you know and that's the fun part of the
artistry is just to keep expanding
what you can do and what you can achieve
you know so
that was like the next frontier for me
i'm like you know what like i want to
make some hits how good did it feel to
get
uh your first solo plaque
incredible i got caught a couple um
but cause tribal and gold right tribal
platinum
platinum yeah damn that's a great job
night job win gold
um obviously down bad it's platinum and
costa rica now i think too
um that's huge man yeah thank you bro
you pulled to the crib you got your your
own
your own plaques yeah i guess that's you
yeah nice
it's definitely it's a blessing bro it's
a blessing like
shout out to the whole team um you know
we've been at it for a minute and it
you know i'm somewhere where people
really believe in that artist's
development
you know you gotta that [ __ ] is a
beautiful thing because you know a lot
of labels they're not
you know what it is man they're they're
looking for that well
and they're also looking for something
that's already on fire so they can just
put some gasoline right right right
something's already viral
yeah dreamville i feel like has done a
superb job of
growing each artist you know what i'm
saying whether it's yourself or arya or
cause like
it's like man it's like you see your
guys just come up
yeah everybody's got a touring base you
know everyone's got an album they could
tour
several albums they can tour um you know
i guess we're kind of like in phase two
now it's like marvel
you know what i mean it's the mcu we're
just going into phase two everybody's
trying to shoot
crazy it's a good that's a good
comparison yeah uh you you mentioned
like being at home a lot during the
pandemic and [ __ ] like
how how did that affect you just you
know because some people i know [ __ ]
with their mental
like especially being an artist you're
not able to you know you probably would
have
been on the road like there would have
probably been some sort of dreamville
tour
right for sure you know what i'm saying
like you know what i think creatively
it helped me tap into some very like
introspective raps that i was
i was missing in a sense because my life
prior to that was like six seven years
on the road and
kind of ingesting all these road
experiences and they're coming out
and this gave me a lot of time to just
sit back and reflect
and like dig deeper on things i wanted
to say
but you know in the same token i was
missing the other side of it i really
like traveling is
like probably the biggest part of of
inspiration for right right yeah going
to these other countries cities whatever
breaking with people collaborating
um so i miss that a lot i miss that a
lot but
you know i think you just got to make
use of
every situation so for me it was like
all right how do i dig deeper how do i
talk about
what's really on my mind how do i talk
about the things i know
you know other people are going through
right now just being isolated
and feeling stagnant you know what i
mean yeah man [ __ ] i mean i had my
[ __ ] kids and my wife and i still
feels like this [ __ ]
sucks yeah especially being in la
because la was like super shut the [ __ ]
down you know
absolutely were you out here most of the
pandemic yeah most of it i
i was gonna go to new york i was gonna
go back home but every time i'm called
i'll just be like bro
like don't even do it so like i flew my
parents out here and had them out here
for like
a couple months i mean that's dope you
probably got to spend some time with
your parents
yeah yeah my nephews like you know
they're like
two and like one that should like force
you to hang out with your family more
for sure for sure bro and even like your
close friends you start to
realize like then there's a lot of
things we don't even talk about
you know what i mean like i learned more
about some of the dudes i've known 15 20
years
in the past year um that i did
knowing them like you know most of my
life it was just
people were in like a more vulnerable
mental state
feel me like but you know that's why you
got a support system
facts man now it's crazy because like
outside of just getting fat as [ __ ]
during the pandemic
yeah i just was trying [ __ ] bro like i
tried mushrooms during the pandemic
i was just had a good ass a few good
acid trips yeah
pandemic yeah yeah like that [ __ ] is you
know i i think
like you said like there was pluses and
minuses and it just depends on your
perspective because some people let that
[ __ ] really like
just take them out you know what i'm
saying yeah take them off the map
and uh i mean you just you know like we
said you gotta keep it perspective
everybody was going through the same
thing
you know what i mean there was times
where like i said you have all these
plans and all these thoughts and all
these goals
and you got to realize like yo nothing's
advancing for anybody right now like
just chill enjoy
there's more i even started thinking we
need like once a decade if it's not a
pandemic
something like that just give people
like six months off yeah feel me like
let everyone work from home for six
months
let everybody regroup yeah you know what
i mean get the experience that's not a
bad idea though once a decade
yeah for sure you say you had some some
so you you you [ __ ] with the
psychedelics
yeah yeah for sure acid as acid
mushrooms
what is i've never done acid i heard
it's like more like extremely visual
um yeah i feel like so it lasts a good
bit longer than mushrooms
your high is probably twice as long the
trip
right but i feel like sometimes with
mushrooms you could kind of get into
like a
a dark spot in the trip definitely where
you're like facing these
these demons or whatever you've been
running right right right and then you
you know usually come out the other side
of
a better person for it right um with
acid like you always know it's the drugs
you know
like you'll start tweaking like oh it's
the drugs i bet [ __ ]
on to the next yeah mushrooms are having
like question your whole life's purpose
take too much there's some moments where
you really have to look yourself in the
mirror
um acid is more like i'm gonna take some
acid i'm gonna have to
you can i can go to the bar yeah i'm
saying you go to the bar you can go
around strangers i can have a full like
intellectual ass convo with a random
stranger on that so on mushrooms i kind
of just want to be with like my core
group
for sure yeah and i had a bad trip when
uh i was in texas
tripping the [ __ ] out man i decided to
go bar hopping after i ate a whole bunch
of shrooms and an edible
yeah you were bold worst decision in my
life you bought your bold i was freaking
the [ __ ] out i it was a bad start
looking at people in the bar like a
stupid face door something crazy no
there was a lady
dancing and her face looked like you
remember on cops back in the day they
used to have their faces scrambled
yeah yeah yeah and there was this [ __ ]
dancing
in front of us and uh i was with
i was with freddie gibbs and i was like
yo fran is
is that [ __ ] we were both on shrooms
i was like
is do you see her face and he's like we
see we saw the same thing
he's like nah it's all [ __ ] up bro
and then some dudes came in i was
paranoid as [ __ ] bro i thought
bro i was i was it was a bad look that
[ __ ]
i'm never doing shrooms ever again in
like a social
area yeah it ain't that but you could do
acid you could do that fine yep
you've ever done dmt nah i have so much
of it in my freezer that my homie
got me on my birthday you have a bunch
in your freezer have a bunch of my
freezer right now
you're gonna have to get a crack pipe
you know that right i'm like trying to
trying to psych you know i like to do
psychedelics right like when i
when i'm either reached a certain like
usually like if i wrap up a project
you know what i mean like it seems like
i'm putting a bow on like a
a moment in life yeah you know what i
mean i like to pick my moments
or maybe if i'm starting a project kind
of deal
um so i like to pick pick yeah you got
to pick and choose that [ __ ] because
yeah it's almost like you you do it as
as you like when you feel like you need
it
exactly like if you kind of know like
maybe if there's a wall or something or
that you can trying to break through or
you know
right right or if it's like all right
what's next right
exactly like give me a little bit of
clarity where am i going with this this
guy got a freezer full of dmt
i do right now at that moment hasn't hit
me yet no i could that [ __ ] doesn't hit
me that shit's like i heard it i've
never done dmt
i want to do it i just can't get my
[ __ ] hands on any of you but oh [ __ ]
i got you that let's say you got
something
but but also i'm like scared because
that's what i'm saying that's where i'm
at with it too like i don't know
you literally have to free base that
[ __ ] and then i heard for like 15
minutes you're just gone
yeah i don't even want no one around you
like you're gone like i had a homie who
said he
he had like a six month like like lived
out six months of his life in his
dmt trip and then woke up and it was
only 15 minutes long
he said he had a girlfriend he had a job
all kinds of [ __ ] that's
crazy so that's why i'm like damn do i i
don't do i wanna
just i don't know i'm exactly where you
at with it like
i wanna do it sitting there like you
know i mean i'll be opening up my fridge
to get some ice and then she's been
staring at me
but i'm like i don't know i don't know
if i'm ready i don't know if i'm ready
i don't know if i'm ready to maybe when
i put this next album out okay
you know what i mean and the jacket
going crazy and i can say you know what
let's let's let's go let's yeah let's go
let's let's go
melt my face off for 20 minutes yeah why
not hey what up man
how to interrupt the bootleg cab podcast
to tell you about our good friends at
odd socks all right yo shout out to them
for
sponsoring the podcast but also for
being such a fire company
and they just introduced their draws
that's right odd socks now got your
boxer briefs
on deck some tapatio joints and then of
course they got the best socks in the
game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loop socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
they got all the licenses breaking bad
mac dre
wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cav and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddssocksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 to check out thank me later um
how is your album done
no it's not done yet it's not done so
it's not done yet it's not done yet
but i mean it could be but
i just got bigger plans for it you know
well you say you're working on another
single
that's gonna be big as well yeah can you
give us a little bit of insight
um it's me and gonna oh
all right you know another another
little collab people wouldn't really
expect
that's true i've been trying to find
people like that and just kind of
sonically
bringing them into my world even like
how we did with tj for sure
you know what i mean um i'm a huge
gunner fan
so you heard it first gunning so that
would be a gunner
boss record you know it's crazy because
i think gunners who kind of like
like low key top baby had a rap for real
yeah
man i love what all those atlanta dudes
do features yeah i think a little baby
is obscene
a little baby lyrically somehow has like
became like a monster
because like 34 years ago when i was
first hearing little bit i was like this
[ __ ] is cool you know some atlanta young
boy [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] is wrapping circles
around everybody right now he's crazy
yeah it's crazy how was it like being in
the studio with gunnar or was that like
nah
he thought yeah it was an email thing it
was like
in the midst of you know coving so no
one was really
like linking up in the studio like that
but yo i heard um
during first of all obviously the uh the
dreamville sessions are
legendary at this point everybody who
got flown into town and
but i heard that chris bosh chris bosh
pulled up
chris pulled up and made some beats yeah
he's
kind of hard too hang on a lot he was in
there with like
uh with cole and t-minus and and diesel
shout out to bros was that like the most
random dude to pull up
no no who who's the most random random
dudes
chris bosh making beats is pretty random
chris basha i mean
that is kind of up there on the random
scale but like
acon was in there at some point with
like his family like just chilling
um the whole milwaukee bucks giannis was
there yeah y'all just came through
nice yeah yeah not making any beats
though nah but they catered like a whole
dinner for us
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it was love shout
out to the bucks man
for real i mean i got issues right now
but yeah yeah they're good people we're
up 2-1 right now
yeah you know what's crazy about the
bucks is i was selling this to my homie
we're at the game
game two like earlier this week or
whatever it was and
i was like damn you know i hated people
on the clippers right
like you know sports hate which is not
the same as like actual hate right
couldn't stand [ __ ] jokic on the
nuggets
uh you know i i'm a lebron fan so i kind
of was indifferent about the laker
series i was like look worst case
scenario
lebron wins he's my favorite player
right even though i i've hated the
lakers my whole life because i'm from
phoenix
right when lebron went over there i
looked the other way for my sport
i feel you on that but the bucks i got
nobody to like hate
like i really [ __ ] with giannis pj
tucker
used to be his son yeah you know what
i'm saying like i like how drew holiday
drew holiday's dope like he's very
humble he don't talk [ __ ]
chris meddleton is like someone who like
his come up in the league has been so
crazy i'm like damn i don't even i can't
even
i want a chance [ __ ] the bucks at the
game but i can't you know i don't feel
it you know what i'm saying i'll feel
you on that they definitely got that
kind of makeup like yeah like who hates
giannis he's like the nicest dude he
stayed down he resigned you know what
i'm saying like
it's crazy what what are you a nick fan
for sure
so i mean [ __ ] man the knicks [ __ ]
you know that was unexpected i didn't
even
know you know nixon six
i mean i'm not gonna lie when when y'all
won that one game
in the series and it acted like it was
the championship outside
i knew it was over it was i know but the
city needed it
no i saw that i said no they're not
winning this series the city needs it
but
you know i mean that's that's about as
good as we've been oh for sure sometimes
so you know
the city got riled up and then it was it
was reopening
right it was like the perfect timing
everybody was yeah yeah they brought all
the all that covert energy outside
have you been um because i've noticed a
lot of my nick friends
they've transferred to the nets which
i've now first of all shout out kd's my
dog
i don't hate on the nets i'm not one of
those knicks fans that hates on the nets
because i
you know i know some players on the team
and and i rock with them so personally i
just want to see them
right right right you're great you feel
me um but no i'm still a next fan
but you noticed a lot of people like
going over to the other side
yeah yeah yeah my sports chat if i
showed you our sports chat right now
that's a big that's a big point of
argument that [ __ ] is crazy like imagine
if like the clippers want to ring this
year
and you started to notice like what i
will say is like
like her face because it'd be the
brooklyn [ __ ] you feel me
so it's like if you're from brooklyn and
yeah like like joe vanes talking [ __ ] to
me like yo the nets are going to get
your sons in the finals and i'm like bro
you're
you weren't you a knicks fan fight like
what is all right he's from brooklyn
okay see ya so you got to get you got to
give them a pass because if a team pops
up in your backyard you know
you kind of gotta just ride with them
that's fair what what where are you from
queens queens is uh i feel like queens
is one of the more interesting boroughs
in all of new york cause for sure
because it's like everything's there
yeah it's it's the most diverse county
so diverse in the world
is it in the world in the world yep that
shit's crazy
yeah we got a little bit of everything
and and
quite possibly i always like you know
what's the better borough
hip-hop all all time is it
brooklyn is it bronze i gotta ride with
coins i think it's
i personally queens is
we have a certain brand of rappers too
like
i mean [ __ ] nas mob deep
50 tribe run dmc hello
no norrie's not from queens norris from
queens no he's from left right now he's
component noriega
cnn yup yeah let's the list goes on man
brooklyn's just
very top-heavy though and we claim cold
so we don't forget that that's fair
cole cole came up and got busy with us
so that's another queen's rapper
you know by way of kind of i think
that's cheating though how he sound like
a queen's rabbit
you listen to cold you sound like from
queens he's from fayetteville bro
i'm just saying though but you know he
he came up when he was what 18 17 that's
fair that's fair
that's fair we claim we claim you know
like half that
is there any discussion uh by the way
shout out to uh eve for i
you know i had to hit him when the
dreamville project came out because
i know that he kind of helped arrange
that and and um
it was such a cohesive project and i
know how hard that is to do
with all the moving parts and i'm sure
the uh the pool of songs to choose from
it had to be crazy and it just it just
it was it played so well front to back
yeah concept that was eve's headache
yeah i was like bro you killed this [ __ ]
the sequencing that like everything was
like even just like some of the artists
that you wouldn't even expect when you
see the track looking like what
what like guap dance on this album
yeah no you know what i'm saying like
yeah i just thought it was such a great
uh you know it almost feels like
an impossible feat to have a compilation
be so just
front to back that's you know there's
been dope compilations of hip i even
think of like diplomatic immunity
there was some [ __ ] on there that i
skipped right i think disc two was the
one that was like most of the skips
right right the dreamville [ __ ] was so
crazy has there any discussion of like
doing it doing the volume four in the
future for sure
we got to do that i feel like three kind
of you know opened a lot of people's
eyes to
because the first two were super slept
on yeah very much so
yeah but you know everything happens for
a reason and
you know within its timing i feel like
when three came around
um we had a lot of artists on the label
that have reached
just new levels on there for sure
whether it was myself
arie jed irv gang who said kaz omen luke
um and then going back to what you said
about how cohesive
it was i think that's because we did it
all in those 10 11 days
that we were everybody was together yeah
everyone was together it was like okay
i'm walking into this session
all right you guys already got like two
verses in the hook let me do a bridge
right or you know i'm walking to this
session all right you know you guys need
a hook
let me try this hook idea you know what
i mean
as opposed to like sending tracks back
and forth and trying to
put this piece it was just literally
like who's in the room who stumbled into
the room like
you know some of those tracks had like
eight people on them
that's real you feel me shows all right
well just keep it to eight bars
because we ain't all doing six teams on
this um
it was a lot of that and it was cool to
see people just process you know artists
have
such a wide range of creative processes
like
some people don't want no one around and
then you see those people
like come out of that show yeah like
because they almost have no choice like
imagine being the guy that goes all the
way to atlanta
right hey can everybody leave yeah yeah
that wasn't going to happen
right you know um so it was cool to see
people just
adapt to each other's creative process
nah i think it was it was done so i mean
volume four has got a
got to be i mean volume three it just
performs so well too
yeah the grammy nom like such a big deal
man
um besides
jackie which has a little tj and colon
and you just mentioned the gunner
is there anybody who's not on your album
yet who you would love
to get a verse from what
um there's a lot of people let me think
i got this record i really want sway
leon
i want to get snow i like snow she's
amazing
she's incredible yeah um
i would love to get whiz kid on the
album yo
whiskey might have the song of the
summer man what that album damn got me
through the whole pandemic honestly made
in legos that got me through the whole
the whole pandemic i was running that um
let's see man there's a there's a lot
honestly the these songs i'm making like
like i said i'm making them from that
standpoint like how do i make these
joints like i don't make these like
major joints
um so i'm doing things that i'm always
hearing
somebody on so i want to get rowdy on
the record i really want to get rowdy
level on the record
that'll be crazy oh yeah
i'm working man hopefully those people i
named when the album come out
we could look back and see well you've
also been like i feel like you've also
haven't been like greedy with like doing
like collabs like
you know you i saw you you were on that
record where that wakoda and i think
joey was on yeah yeah that's just
super dope yep um what what are some
like uh
like like you you mentioned the whisk is
that whiz kid album
on the hip hop side we're just like the
[ __ ] that you've really been
just that's on repeat in the whip for
you on spotify
a lot of like the the brooklyn drill
scene honestly
actually it's going up man i just i just
wouldn't hung out with dusty lokane and
canarsie and yeah yeah yeah and uh who
else we were hanging out with ross swish
yeah that [ __ ] is going crazy as far as
like the hip-hop i've
just been been running through all those
cats yeah now the drill yeah
chef jesus is crazy yeah um
two two g's i know like they got dates
that's the problem
like everybody got their issues but bro
i had no i had a neutral party i'm i'm
over here listening to all that like
it was hard i had no idea how crazy
that [ __ ] was like the woos and the
chose or whatever
in new york yeah yeah it's it's just
going up yeah we went we went to new
york for like a week
we went to buffalo and chill with
griselda and then like we're
i'm doing some original content um
almost like some hip hop anthony
bourdain [ __ ] with empire
so we like we did a bunch of stuff with
the drill guys
and we were just in the hotel room like
like let's see what's going on you know
and
watch this whole documentary about that
whole [ __ ] i'm like this [ __ ] is crazy
that's why they wouldn't let nobody do
that rolling loud a couple years ago
remember there was
yeah yeah that's when they took pop
smoke off
yeah yeah that shit's crazy though yeah
it's wild i had like no idea bro like
i think it was a chef was it chef g that
got stabbed you got stabbed in the head
or some [ __ ]
yeah he was just damn i don't even know
all that yeah [ __ ] is nuts
like meanwhile but they're making
really good music they're making great
music you know you got to hope
yeah you know everybody matures to level
past that but you know that [ __ ]
that we don't even know about you know
what i mean that's just like
[ __ ] they all been dealing with i
imagine imagine
boss doing a drill record though you
know what i'm saying that because i got
something in the tuck
it'd be so random i got some oh it's
coming oh it's coming don't even worry
about
it okay don't even worry about it uh how
you feeling uh you know obviously you're
a big basketball guy
how you feeling about my phoenix sons
man you know book is my dude
book book book is like when you say he's
your dude like he's your friend
yeah he's somebody i've been rocking
with drinking a girl from like early
like early like i remember
i think we was in vegas once and like
buck wasn't even 21 yet you know the
vegas clubs don't play that right right
right so like he's a he's a dude that
been like just supporting us from jump
um so i really want to see him win and
cp3 but then obviously we know we got a
lot of homies on i mean obviously
they've catered you guys dinner and
devin booger didn't come to your [ __ ]
session yeah you're right
you're right that's a good point i mean
so you're you are you you're just kind
of like whoever wins you're coolest
you know what though i do want to see
chris paul get one because i
i think out of everyone playing his
legacy would
gain the most solidified it'd be so
solidified top five point guard
i think he's a top five point guard
already but but that
nobody can say especially the way he's
led that team and the way he's made
those pieces like even like last year on
the thunder
they were a five seed bro they thought
they were going to tank and be in the
lottery
and chris paul had them that
[ __ ] playing bro
he's about years 16 now so like that
window
is shrinking so you know i'm i'm i'm
ruin i'm rooting for the suns
for but you know i think giannis is
going to get his i think they're going
to have their time
yeah giannis is still young man exactly
i want to see chris ball get one before
it's over
yeah cp3 is that guy who would you
consider to be the cp3 of rap
the cp3 of rap like somebody who's like
maybe doesn't get that acknowledgement
but it's like an all-time great what
they do you understand
that's a great that's a great one trying
to think who's the chris paul a rap
who is a cr right you got to answer that
one
because also chris paul makes everyone
around him better i'm trying to think of
that person too you know
i don't know that's a tough one
that is really tough nitrane you ain't
got nobody
cole he said cole cole got his rings
though
cole got his rings man you got a few of
them rings yeah
forgot them rings yeah the rings yeah
i'm trying to think of someone who might
be like
less appreciated yeah maybe like
i don't know maybe somebody like 50 40.
e40 you do he make the bae he 40. he
make the big jump for real
yeah that's hard i like that that's not
a bad one e40
you i'll let you have that man i let you
have that yeah yeah i'll let you have
that bay area over there
this guy tried to tell me mag dre was
the most influential rapper of all time
no no no no you didn't say one of them
you no no no no no no
no he said no no no you didn't say that
when we
now you saying that because the camera
no he said
the most influential rapper ever
you're [ __ ] on drugs whatever they
smoking on in the bay we got to talk
he on dmt for sure you hear what i'm
saying shout out to mac dre rest in
peace he's a legend you know what i'm
saying an icon in your area for sure
but he is one of those dudes though like
as you know as a new yorker like
when you think you're the bae you think
of mac dre you think of mac dre
40 but like you play this song still to
this day nobody in new york is playing
this song
crazy they go crazy yeah in a certain
part of the country they go crazy
but you can't say he's the single most
influential rapper
ever for the region
okay are you accepting defeat in the
argument
so he's more than i mean he's got an
oakland a's hat on you're not so he's
more influential than hove or tupac
or [ __ ] rock him
you didn't say that though [ __ ] out of
here bro you didn't say that
now you're saying that little wayne's
more influential come on bro anyway well
look uh
hopefully in any timeline where we gonna
get the album besides just before the
end of the year
um i'm hoping for like
q4 okay yeah
i got a few things i want to i want to
get out there
is everyone working like everyone on the
team right now working on on
on projects od od od everybody
everybody going crazy yeah i thought it
was super dope to see earth gang have
like one of them records that like did
well on radio
options yeah options did it shut up uh
ghetto guys on the way and and you know
obviously just
jid is one of the he's an alien i always
say there's like certain people who are
like
uh jedi's in hip-hop and he's like
lyrically a jedi
yeah yeah that record he put out with
conway is [ __ ] crazy
he went crazy on there so he's working
on his [ __ ] uh
obviously cole's probably relaxing right
now i'd assume
i don't even know you never know what
cole you just never know right you never
know what cole he got
you know he's on that path to the fall
falloff i think he's trying to get
everything off his chest that he wants
to i want to see i want to see cause and
reason do our album together man
me too me too i would love it i would
love that
i'll really love that lambo truck is
like such a great like
it was like such a perfectly executed
concept yeah
i was like yo d y'all got to do that it
was on something like how to ride
[ __ ] but like the west coast version
they got to do an album bro
i know reason said he's down i i think
you know obviously there's
two separate camps well not even two i
think it's feasible
you know if those two made the music i
don't think anybody would stand it would
be the
cole and kendrick album we never got but
on a lesser scale
you know what i'm saying yeah i feel
that yeah i think that
that's what it would be who would you if
you could do a collab album with like
like anybody who you got real chemistry
with who you really [ __ ] with like who
would you do a collab project with
i'm not saying it's going to happen i'm
saying like if you have i mean the
easiest collab project would probably be
with coal
because we just got we already damn
there got one
if i got to pick anybody um
yeah coal would be a layup that's easy
though pharrell
perrell yeah but i like i want him
rapping i'm a skateboard p
yeah yeah yeah not just on the
production side like
there it is man well look hey boss i
appreciate you pulling up hopefully we
get uh this album sooner than later yeah
the song jackie is out let's get it
it's going crazy yes sir congratulations
i think it's
already like 5 million on spotify just
been out for like a week yeah
yeah that's going up shout out to
everybody supporting all the dj's
kev appreciate each other boom the homie
boss